now well many people love HOAs because
they keep neighborhoods nice but one
local homeowner says he's getting the
run around from his homeowners
association thank you so much for
staying with us here at 4 30 I'm
Christian Casas and I'm Kirsten Joyce
Mary Jane bellies shares one homeowner's
frustrations due to a landscaping
violation
a homeowner in a Northwest Valley
neighborhood is trying to stay in
compliance with his HOA but is having a
hard time getting answers so he reached
out to 8 news now I'm going to take out
the plants that are in there and put
them in the ground if I can Ryan
Gustafson first purchased his home in
2018 he's recently been hit this summer
with the Landscaping violation for not
having enough plants in his yard it's
been the same as the day I bought it
really so it'd suddenly be hit with this
violation there I feel like they're four
years late Gustafson says his HOA first
service residential is requiring a plan
for every 25 square feet of rock the
tree in his yard doesn't count as a
plant and potted plants aren't allowed
he says the HOA also hasn't specified
what types of plants he needs these are
things that I only learn by sending them
email after email trying to get more
information it's not clear anywhere in
their architectural guideline plan it's
not clear in the violation paperwork
that they gave me the plants must also
have a drip irrigation system system the
fact that we have to increase the amount
of water that we're pouring into our
yards at a time when our lake is at like
the biggest low that it's ever been at
just doesn't make any sense to me now a
few months later Gustafson is trying to
play catch-up after missing a few HOA
meetings he says he's trying to do the
best he can to follow their guidelines
and has reached out to his HOA on what
he needs to do if I'm in violation tell
me that I'm in violation of what I need
to do to fix it that should be the bare
minimum and what I'm finding is that
they can't seem to tell me what I need
to do in order to fix the problem
Gustafson says there is an HOA meeting
scheduled in October he plans to attend
so he can get clarification and that
could help his neighbors too reporting
from Durango and Cheyenne Mary Jane
beliesza 8 News Now